n'aime pas revenir devant l'hôpital de
cette île
ce lieu était à jamais associé pour elle
aux souvenirs de son frère étendu au sol
sans vie
il y avait un visage qui me disait tout
de suite Martin ne vit plus le cœur de
Martin s'est arrêté pendant que deux
agents de la Sûreté du Québec tentait de
le maîtriser ni le coronaire ni
l'enquête indépendante qui a suivi non
condamné l'intervention policière
mais la famille a des doutes
[Applaudissements]
c'est un ovodose qui a fait puis moi je
me disais
aucun bon sens je veux pas qu'il y ait
dire en gros c'est juste la peur des
policiers c'est juste la peur de
l'hôpital
chose que ça passait du début de son
histoire aller que Martin soit d'un lit
d'hôpital intubé il a je peux pas
imaginer encore aujourd'hui après six
ans et demi que mon frère est décédé
comme ça
[Musique]
martin est un bon vivant mon comique mon
clown tu sais
Martin Collard 36 ans vient d'une
famille tricotée serrée il était proche
de sa sœur Gaëtane les deux se parlaient
presque tous les jours et prenez soin de
moi-même c'était le petit frère c'est le
matin n'importe quand qui travaillait
pas le matin il a porté mon petit café
au moment des faits Martin mène une vie
tranquille travaille depuis 10 ans pour
la compagnie minière iOS et il vient de
rompre avec son ami de coeur
il y avait de la peine cette fin de
semaine extrêmement
très grosse peine d'amour très grosse
peine d'amour mon frère
et
comme il traverse un moment difficile ce
soir d'octobre 2015 Gaëtane et sa tante
Thérèse passe la soirée avec lui il dit
mais c'est pas j'attends juste que vous
partez pour boirer ma porte puis me
coucher puis dormir puis demain on sort
tout le monde ensemble enfin qu'on a dit
on a passé
puis en pleine nuit le téléphone sonne
chez Gaetane
j'ai vu le numéro j'ai fait ok
au téléphone je demande sa voiture
Martin non ça va pas vraiment tu es où
tu es où
Martin est dans un bar rue Brochu il a
consommé de la cocaïne et se sent mal je
dis Martin
Martin se plaint de palpitations sur le
conseil de sa sœur il part à pied vers
l'hôpital il me dit
est-ce que tu me juges la tête
de ta fille de la petite que je veux
vivre si je vois à l'hôpital que je veux
vivre chez lui et oui Martin
c'est certain
j'ai quand même promis que le monde
était là pour l'aider
qu'elle vive parce qu'il voulait vivre
Martin
pauvre Martin
pour décortiquer la suite des événements
nous avons fait appel à deux experts
le détective chorse MC a travaillé 30
ans au service de police de Los Angeles
il est un pionnier en Amérique du Nord
dans la formation des policiers en
intervention de crise
[Musique]
Michael aruda ex policier au SPVM
pendant 25 ans aujourd'hui formateur est
un des très rares experts reconnus dans
ce type d'intervention au Québec
l'élément clé est cette vidéo captée par
la caméra de surveillance de l'hôpital
la famille a mis des années à l'obtenir
dans le cadre d'une poursuite qu'elle a
entreprises allons-y
aux alentours de 4 heures alerté par le
bruit des employés découvrent Martin
devant la porte principale au lieu de
celle de l'urgence alors Martin arrive
de la rue Évangéline se présente là
l'urgence est ici on peut présumer qu'il
cherche un endroit pour rentrer
une infirmière demande à Martin de
contourner le bâtiment pour se rendre à
l'urgence Gaëtan n'est toujours au
téléphone avec lui et capte une partie
des échanges
Martin gesticule crie dit que l'hôpital
va exploser et commence à enlever son
pantalon combien de personnes qu'on sait
que qui crie à 4h du matin qui
t'entraîne se déshabiller au milieu de
la rue qui effectivement tient des
propos incohérents c'est quelque chose
qui va pas c'est pas ton criminel
typique c'est quelqu'un qui est en
détresse
[Musique]
on voit l'infirmière qui décide de faire
appel à la police c'est le premier point
tournant de la soirée
une personne en détresse psychologique
blanc 5 pieds 8 gilet noir cellulaire
casquette probablement plus de pantalons
avec un peu d'informations qu'on a déjà
on sait qu'on s'envoie dans une
intervention ou un appel pour une
personne en détresse on sait que c'est
pas quelque chose de de qui met là de
danger est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui
est dérangeant plus que dangereux on est
en train de déjà faire des scénarios
pendant que les policiers sont en route
les employés parviennent presque à
convaincre Martin d’entrer de son plein
gré selon ce que nous a affirmé au moins
une des personnes qui étaient sur place
à ses yeux Martin n'avait rien de
menaçant
mais la tension augmente subitement
quand deux agents de la Sûreté un homme
et une femme arrive sur les lieux Martin
est toujours au téléphone avec sa tante
Thérèse qui a pris la relève
Martin
œdipe
des policiers j'ai rien fait de mal
pourquoi les policiers ils comprenaient
pas qu'il y ait demandé de l'aide à
l'hôpital
puis les premiers qui voient arriver
c'est les policiers
d'un citoyen qui est pas en situation de
crise il y a un stress qui va augmenter
mais imaginez-vous quelqu'un qui est
déjà dans un état de panique
le policier explique dans des documents
de cours qu'il a essayé de jaser avec
Martin mais que celui-ci refuse de dire
son nom comme s'il se foutait de moi un
peu il ne me regardait pas
[Musique]
n'est-ce pas
on va essayer de désescalader ramener la
personne dans un état qu'on peut se
parler l'objectif c'est de rassurer
quelqu'un un intervention association
crise ne dure pas des minutes ça peut
durer des heures ça peut durer quelques
heures
mais le policier dit avoir peur que
Martin s'enfuit
on va le laisser promener ça prend le
temps que ça prend il y a pas d'urgence
d'agir
bien que des renforts soient déjà en
route sans attendre leur arrivée un des
agents intervient il saisit Martin par
le bras c'est quelque chose qu'on
enseigne et qu'on dit puis qu'on répète
on a tout juste jamais quelqu'un qui est
en crise on touche jamais quelqu'un qui
est en crise parce qu'on sait jamais
comment être la personne va réagir
l'intervention policière vient de
prendre un nouveau tournant qui sera
fatale
[Musique]
au Québec au moins le quart des
interactions avec la police implique des
gens dont l'état mental est altéré comme
pour Martin drogue et police peuvent
devenir un dangereux cocktail on le sait
que ce phénomène-là existe depuis au
moins 30 ans c'est arrivé avec l'affaire
CorSec
[Musique]
le joueur de Hakim est mort hier soir à
Québec dans des circonstances
troublantes cordique et cet ancien dur à
cuire des Canadiens et des Nordiques
morts en 1992 au cours d'une
intervention policière musclée c'était
les premiers fois qu'on voit sur un
intervention policière avec quelqu'un
qui avait consommé qui est en état de
panique et en état d'excitation on
voyait déjà ces symptômes blancs à
comment intervenir il faut faire
attention quand on rencontre quelqu'un
qui est dans cet état là
revoici Martin agité et sans son
pantalon en hyperthermie des signes
manifestent d'intoxication puis sans
raison apparente la vidéo s'interrompt
ça arrivera souvent
quand elle reprend 8 minutes plus tard
les policiers sont sur place l'un d'eux
CESI Martin par le
Brasil se dit par le bras il part à
courir TV juste
Martin s’éloigne à deux coins de rue
suivi par les deux policiers là ils vont
aller chercher ses effets là il rentre
avec leurs effets le personnel en
profite pour rentrer vêtements et
chaussures de Martin à l'intérieur il
s'attendent manifestement à ce que les
policiers amènent Martin à l'urgence
dehors Martin s'est arrêté à
l'intersection de l'avenue Gamache il
s'accroche toujours à sa sœur au bout du
fil
je Martin Martin ça va bien aller car
pense moi les policiers pense moi un
policier je veux parler à quelqu'un
réussite à parler aux policiers et à
prévenir qu'elle s'en vient on se
parlait mais mon dessin on ange lui dit
j'ai dit que il est en peine dans mon
j'ai expliqué le tout il était triste et
il y avait consommé imaginez-vous
l'information que vous venez de me
donner là je sais dans quel état je
connais son nom son prénom son nom de
famille je connais c'est quoi pourquoi
qui est de même le délément déclencheur
de la crise
rupture amoureuse il y a consommé de la
cocaïne et ton mentale perturbé
selon l'expert le policier rate ici une
occasion de créer un lien de confiance
il redonne le téléphone à Martin après
ça
plus rien comme si
écoute il y a même pas dit merci il y a
rien dit dans la seconde dans le 2
secondes j'ai entendu un cri de mort de
pleurs de plats
qui reste dans la mémoire
pour moi c'est là que ça se passe
c'est le moment où le policier a essayé
de prendre le bras de Martin pour le
retenir une deuxième fois puis j'ai
échappé la prise d'utile il m'a glissé
des mains
[Musique]
Martin repart les deux policiers assez
trousses Amélie Thibault observe la
scène depuis son balcon en face
j'entendais quelqu'un qui courir dans la
rue puis des gens qui criaient puis on
s'est levé c'est là qu'on a vu qu'il y
avait un homme qui courait dans le
stationnement et il y avait une
policière qui courait derrière lui elle
voulait que s'arrête se mobilise puis la
personne semble être plus en panique
puis elle est très elle vous laisse
décentrer elle voulait pas s'arrêter là
est-ce qu'il y avait l'air dangereuse
monsieur l'eau du tout pas du tout
le policier décrit la suite Martin court
en direction de l'hôpital il tentait
d'ouvrir les portes verrouillées je lui
ai fait une encolure
la brutalité du geste a suscité ce
commentaire d'un témoin qui habitait en
face c'est là que le temps a changé le
flex est mis à lui crier après puis il
s'est jeté dessus un sauvage pour le
maîtriser
[Musique]
quand la vidéo reprend les deux hommes
sont déjà par terre on ne sait pas
depuis combien de temps il y a des
jambes qui t’entraînent de bouger il est
en mode survie il veut se débarque il
veut sortir de là
le policier admettra avoir utilisé son
poids pour maîtriser Martin au sol en
maintenant l'encolure l'encolure vise à
exercer une pression sur les artères
carotides pour provoquer une perte de
conscience en moins de 15 secondes mais
sur la bande vidéo Martin reste
conscient il tente de se dégager de
toutes ses forces
[Musique]
le risque est de bloquer les voies
respiratoires
moi je personnellement c'est une
technique que j'aurais jamais suggéré à
qui que ce soit de l'appliquer auprès
d'une personne surtout sur une personne
qui est en crise
Martin lutte pendant au moins deux
longues minutes à 4h20 et 2 secondes sur
la vidéo c'est la dernière fois qu'on
voit Martin Gouget puis la vidéo
s'interrompt à nouveau
[Musique]
Gaetane n'a jamais raccroché elle a
déposé le téléphone le temps de se
préparer à partir quand elle reprend le
combiné elle entend des mots qu'il a
entre
tout de suite que un agent crie à mon
frère Martin et Martin ça criait Martin
entendu puis que la panique était là et
le dit après Zara fallu la spam de ton
plus
désemparé
vite vite quand je la porte dans la
porte je pars
la spume c'est la police autochtone la
seule disponible pour venir en renfort
ce soir là à l'heure arrivée l'un d'eux
me note Martin toujours sous contrainte
en le retournant tout de suite il
reconnaît Martin un ami d'enfance qui
vient de son village et constate qu'il
ne respire plus
on entendait le policier qui disait à
Martin reste avec nous reste avec nous
là chez nous pour le matin puis après ça
la polystère elle s'est aperçue que les
gens l'observaient sentiez-vous beaucoup
de tension j'étais paniquée on vient de
se rendre compte qu'il ne respire plus
on est on a sauté deux minutes à peu
près
rapidement ça c'est un des renforts s'en
va vers l'urgence en espérant trouver de
l'aide policière numéro 2 qui est dans
un état d'énervement important on sent
qu'elle est extrêmement inquiète je
pense
par radio la policière demande l'aide
d'un médecin ou d'une infirmière parce
que l'homme n'est plus là
[Musique]
dehors on commence les manœuvres de
réanimation
le policier est parti chercher de l'aide
revient bredouille
[Musique]
nouvelle interruption de la bande vidéo
c'est là que gettane arrive à son tour
sur les lieux il était couché sur le
balcon en boxeur sur le ciment les mains
derrière me noter
je vais mis à genoux
je voulais être très il y avait un
visage qui me disait tout de suite il y
a plus rien Martin ne vit plus
4h26 on discerne sur la vidéo qui
redémarre la présence de l'infirmière
revenue sur les lieux avec un préposé et
un gardien de sécurité
c'est pas c'est un code de médecin c'est
un médecin qu'on veut
quand l'infirmière demande l'aide du
personnel de l'urgence on lui répond on
ne sort pas parce qu'on a pas le droit
alors j'ai demandé à la gente sécurité
dit-elle puis au préposé d'aller me
chercher une civière
puis par après on a vu les les
secouristes qui sont venus avec une
civière ils ont fait le tour de la porte
d'urgence et on passait le garage ils
sont venus jusqu'à 9 ans c'est quand
qu'ils ont bougé pour le mettre sur la
civière a dit je peux pas faire de
massage avec des menottes mais ça donne
absolument rien de faire des manœuvres
avec quelqu'un qui qui a des malades
dans le dos au niveau respiratoires de
pomper quelqu'un ça peut causer plus de
dommages que d'autres choses
[Musique]
Martin arrive finalement à l'urgence à
4h34
dans son rapport le gardien de sécurité
écrit que le médecin a sauvé le patient
[Musique]
mais Martin a manqué d'oxygène trop
longtemps
il ne reprendra jamais conscience
et sera débranché trois jours plus tard
[Musique]
celle qui tient la caméra c'est la fille
de Martin
elle avait 14 ans quand elle a perdu son
père son grand complice je m'ennuie
tellement de toi et Christelle dans une
publication Facebook surtout de nourrir
à toute tête
Martin garder son enfant
pratiquement seul dans ces temps-là
c'est avec l'aide d'entourage mais je
sais comme maman est comme papa
c'était sa vie c'était sa fille
mon cadeau à moi m'a été enlevé son
préavis et avec force écrit la jeune
fille jamais je me remettrai de ta perte
[Musique]
la famille Collard reste avec beaucoup
de questions plusieurs règles de
l'intervention de crise semble avoir été
empreinte sans que personne ne soit tenu
responsable
il y a des procédures dans les guides
des pratiques policières qui viennent du
ministère de la Sécurité publique
l'objectif c'est toujours de l'amener à
l'urgence sans jamais utiliser la force
ces procédures les voici
une personne en délire agitée comme des
agents des crimes Martin risque de
décéder subitement pendant ou après un
effort physique il faut privilégier la
désescalade faire appel à des renforts
éviter d'appliquer une pression sur son
dos la placer en position latérale afin
d'éviter l'asphyxie tout pour ne pas
mettre sa vie en danger
[Musique]
mais moins de 10 minutes se sont écoulés
entre l'arrivée des policiers et le
moment où l'un d'eux décide à lui seul
de maîtriser Martin
minimum de 4 à 5 policiers pour
effectivement pour qu'on puisse
contrôler chacun des membres c'est à
dire les jambes et la tête les deux bras
évitez la lutte qui oblige Martin à
déployer des efforts physiques dangereux
pour son cœur affecté par la cocaïne
plus de force qu'on met sur l'individu
plus l'individu va se débattre plus
d'efforts que ça prend plus qu'un danger
que la personne de cette par la suite
l'encolure appliquée ici par des
policiers en formation correspondent à
un niveau de force puissant
habituellement limité au cas d'agression
potentiellement mortelles
le policier a considéré que Martin était
potentiellement dangereux et qu'il
n'était pas capable de le menotter en
raison de sa résistance c'est la
résistance pour quelqu'un qui pense
qu'il va mourir si je pense que je vais
mourir vous allez voir que n'importe qui
n'importe qui va se débattre
le policier n'avait jamais fait
d'encolure en 5 ans de métiers ni reçu
de mise à jour depuis sa formation
initiale sa partenaire ne l'avait jamais
utilisé non plus en 28 ans de carrière
au niveau de la désescalade au niveau de
l'intervention de crise au niveau de la
communication malheureusement
il y a très peu de service de police qui
donne cette formation là au policier on
laisse les policiers patrouilleurs à
eux-mêmes à dire des bruits
à faire et malheureusement c'est des
situations qu'on voit
[Musique]
malgré ses ratés le Directeur des
poursuites criminels et pénales a estimé
que les policiers n'avaient pas eu
d'autres choix que de maîtriser Martin
par la force il sait plus entre autres
sur l'enquête réalisée par la police de
Québec cette enquête fait état de ce
formulaire où le policier a coché que
Martin avait un couteau il y avait bien
un coup de pêche parmi ses vêtements
dont il s'est débarrassé rapidement sur
le perron de l'hôpital et qu'on a
ramassé rappelez-vous bien avant que les
policiers tentent de le maîtriser
peut-être on irait voir
plus loin qu'on aurait écouté peut-être
d'autres gens qui arrivent d'autres
choses à dire qu'on aurait peut-être
laisser l'histoire un petit peu
sortir un peu
la famille se demande pourquoi des
témoins comme cet employé qu'on voit
observer la scène longuement non pas été
rencontrés par les enquêteurs Amélie
Thibault n'a pas été interrogé non plus
j'ai jamais rencontré un policier à ce
sujet là est-ce que vous vous attendiez
ce qui vient de vous voir ben ça aurait
été en quelque sorte normal puisque on
était témoin direct
le rapport d'autopsie discute aussi les
policiers en déclarant trait improbable
que l’intervention policière est
contribuée à l'arrêt cardio-respiratoire
le pathologiste conclut que la cocaïne
et la cause du décès trois experts
médicaux retenus par la famille conteste
ses conclusions
je sais à vous dire mon total des
accords à cette affirmation la cause de
l'arrêt cardiaque est multifactorielle
la France très improbable que
l'intervention policière est contribuée
de quelques façons et grossièrement
trompeuse et
erronée
ces experts sont unanimes et si les
policiers avaient été témoins agressifs
écrits l'un d'eux Martin serait-il resté
conscient oui le pital n'est pas épargné
non plus si Monsieur Collard avait eu
accès aux urgences dès à son arrivée
serait-il en vie aujourd'hui réponse
oui
et rappelez-vous aussi que le personnel
de l'urgence a refusé de porter secours
à Martin alors qu'il était en arrêt
cardio respiratoire
craignant que les assurances n'allaient
pas les couvrir à l'extérieur des murs
de l'hôpital une légende urbaine
explique l'infirmière qui est sorti
quand même et qui s'est fait dire par
des collègues qu'elle n'aurait pas dû
c'est une fausse croyance il faut sortir
je faisais quelqu'un et un malaise c'est
pas vrai que tu peux t'appeler parce que
c'est pas assuré
elle a raison les directives du
ministère de la santé sont claires la
responsabilité de l'hôpital envers le
patient débute dès que ce dernier a
entre sur son terrain le ci3s de la côte
nord a décliné notre demande d'entrevue
mais affirme que Martin a reçu tous les
soins requis
Sarah dû pas finir de même si elle est
un ovodo ils sont où du monde surtout
chez près de l'hôpital
[Musique]
Martin fait maintenant partie des
statistiques
entre 2006 et 2015 17 personnes sont
mortes sous contrainte lors d'une
intervention policière comme Martin
toutes les victimes avaient consommé des
stimulants neuf fois sur 10 on a conclu
que la drogue était l'unique cause du
décès
je pense que la majorité des policiers
incluant ceux qui font des enquêtes il y
a une méconnaissance au niveau de
l'intervention auprès des personnes qui
ont des problèmes de santé mentale
et le cas de Martin n’est sans doute pas
unique
longtemps qu'on n'a pas changé nos
façons de faire que les organismes les
services de police on prend bien compris
on peut bien saisi qu'est-ce qu'on
devrait faire malheureusement c'est pas
unique qui va en avoir d'autres
challenge
[Musique]
récemment le procureur général du Québec
a admis qu'en rétrospective
l'intervention policière n'est pas
entièrement conforme aux règles de l'art
mais continue d'affirmer qu'elle n'a pas
causé de préjudice à Martin Collard la
Sûreté du Québec a décliné notre demande
d'entrevue
mais ça mal viré ça aurait été tellement
simple d'avoir des torts la mémoire
Martin sera toujours là mais on n'aurait
pas toutes ces questionnements cette
tristesse et à vivre avec ça encore
en poursuivant la police et l'hôpital de
cette île la famille espère que toute la
lumière soit faite sur les circonstances
de sa mort
c'est la fin d'une vie c'est
au froid que ce soit
un commencement à d'autres choses
mais il faut qu'on passe une étape il
faut qu'on pense
toujours souriant comme ça
[Musique]